Britany what was your life like before
August 9th 2014 before August 9th I was
still an undergrad so school work I
worked up to two jobs are throughout
undergrad I worked for a nursing agency
back at home and I also worked like
retail and I was a waitress I still you
know mothering my daughter and traveling
I've traveled abroad with you know
someone who I was with at the time and I
travelled across the country a lot it
was very it was not as stressful I also
did not have anxiety the way that I have
anxiety now it was a completely
different life it was like okay so then
the day of August 9th or the really be
probably August 10th when it is when you
found out I found out August 9 I was
actually out of town I was in New York
with some friends and I was scrolling
through Facebook and I first saw them
Facebook a friend of mine from college
was he meant status and I said Provost
just shot and killed a kid and he's
still in the middle of the street like
this just doesn't seem right so then i
go to twitter twitter it's like more of
a big deal people are like taking photos
and i kept in the faroe being retweeted
on my timeline who is the person who
knew my brown they shot him in front of
his apartment and that's when I really
was like wow this is not a joke like
this is like real and they had a body
picture of a body just floating down my
timeline and from that moment I was just
glued to my phone and completely sucked
out of my element and I was not enjoying
myself anymore
I was just completely glued to my phone
for the rest of my trip
all night I just kept kept scrolling
through Twitter I was watching videos of
the police pulled dogs out on protesters
and I think I don't know if it was the
first night of the second night of me
watching from afar where this police
officer pulled his rifle out on
protesters and caught him
animals and I was like I got to get home
like immediately so I think the people
who are showering was kind of knew that
I was kind of out of my element you know
I couldn't really enjoy myself had knots
in my stomach the whole time I kept
touching bases folks back at home a
little brother was getting ready to go
off to school and my mom was texting me
telling me that she's trying to get him
out of the city as soon as possible so
they drove all the way down a New Mexico
to drop him off at school early he was
going into Mexico State University it
was just a very hard time for this city
and for people in the city who were
watching what was happening like in our
backyard you know because people say
Ferguson on TV like that's how we
nationally have come to know st. Louis
by Ferguson but that same rule is you
know and the entire city was was moved
one way or another by what had happened
when Mike Brown was murdered
left laying in the street did not call
an ambulance you know and then the
uprising occurred it had an impact on
everyone how far from where you live was
his body film at that time I was living
in South st. Louis it's about a 20
minute drive okay oh yeah pretty close
it's not very far and on and you have a
brother that's around his age so my
brother is now 21 at the time I think of
same age right
so I know I'm not sure if it was you who
had said this in a prior interview but
somebody did that it was really not a
protest at first it was going to become
a gathering yeah people are going to go
out there and and maybe hold a vigil
something like that but at what point
did these gatherings become actual
protest and you turn your life over
basically to this I would say when when
folks gathered together when the night
had happened it was the police response
that sparked an uprising these were
people from that community and from the
outlying communities different parts of
saying we was coming together to mourn a
loss in the most despicable way you know
and to be met with the type of
aggression and force that people were
met with by the police that is what
caused the uprising it was people in
positions of power treating civilians
like we like literally like we were
animals making people walk in circles
and talking to people like they had no
right to feel grief they had no rights
or more so it was supposed to be
official it was supposed to be people
getting together to hold space for my
friend but being a man with dogs tear
gas I mean mace and rifles and riot here
that made it what it was and prior to
August 9th 2014
just just quickly what was your life
like going to the store was it did you
feel as persecuted as the way you see in
this footage of either the night after
the shooting or or other consciousness
so so what is your life like just
driving just be oh do you feel watched
you feel like you're scrutinized and
Samuel is always those I think the way
that I feel being
a black woman now has it didn't just
happen after August 9th
whether it was driving or whether it was
me existing in predominantly white
spaces whether it was me walking into a
store I've always been aware of my
blackness and in some cases how my
blackness intersects was my woman knows
when I go into certain spaces very aware
of it I think most black people are you
know because we have to be so I think
after August 9th and st. Louis tensions
racial tension has always always been in
st. Louis but it heightened to the point
to where people became a little bit more
blatant you know they want they want you
to know where they stand what they
believe in makes the tension a lot lot
more thick thicker you know um but
nothing really changed about my
experience except I might wear a lot of
people a little bit of them the wrong
way now because I'm more public and open
about how I feel as far as my politics
are concerned and it's just one of those
types of things or people they don't
agree with you they want you to know
that they don't agree with you they want
you to feel like you're wrong and
they're right and why you know but
that's really it I was just reading an
article yesterday and it was about when
you decide to take your life to a
different spot that's different from how
everybody else is going to challenges
people oh yeah and maybe people that you
think would embrace you actually feel
either threatened or maybe even envious
yeah you're doing something that they
secretly wish they could it's been as
far as my relationships with people
I've had people distance themselves for
me not wanting to be associated
I've had people silently agree with what
I'm saying you know people say I can't
really say those things I can't really
make those statements but every time you
do inside I'm like
you know and I'm like well you know it
just comes it comes with the territory
you know I don't really dwell on the
fact that there are people who are
envious of this kind of work I don't
understand that I don't know what it's
going to be envious about it's just
doing the work it's so much for
everybody to do you know so that I don't
I don't really dwell on that what I what
I prioritize is black people what I
prioritize is doing the work however I
can do it and focusing on what I'm
capable of doing staying in my lane
that's all I can really do it shows you
in the film at various points saying
you're either here with us on the front
line well just go home basically yeah a
lot of people would come inspect inspect
to keep is that a word
like they would like wanted like fair
spectators they would want to like watch
see what what happened and it's like no
you like things can go from zero to 60
very quickly as far as the rest are
concerned as far as being attacked by
the cops being tear gas and these I
don't like feeling responsible when
folks come out to actions and then they
get hurt or they get arrested and they
weren't plan to so if I put a call out
and I let everybody know it's a red
action meaning that the chances of
seeing arrests are very very high do not
come and you come anyway just to watch
that's this is not this isn't a football
game this isn't you know we're not
playing recreational sports this is
organized civil disobedience and you are
either participating in it or you're not
you know so the spectators when they
come to things like that I just don't
think it's the right place or the right
time for it I do feel responsible when
folks come to stuff and they didn't want
to get arrested with their parents
especially if I organized it
and I feel like I wasn't clear enough
about my action you know I wasn't clear
enough about the risk and I just I don't
like putting people in those types of
positions so I'm sure everybody knows
that they're getting themselves into
when they make the choice to show up but
still it's just one of those things that
you don't just stand around and to just
watch you know so I do like for people
to show up if they're going to be active
they're going to take a risk if they're
going to you know participate in civil
disobedience it just gets very stressful
when people are there to watch unless
they're legal observers or unless
they're documenting I just don't think
it's really appropriate because it's
worked like it's we're doing to work you
know speaking of a football game or or
sports game what do you think people are
so some people are offended by the hands
up statement I don't know why people are
offended by that well the the Vorta
forgive me on not football fan but
weren't the st. Louis there were four
football players who decided to in
solidarity do the hands up I feel like
the people who are offended by that were
the same people who are totally against
the movement in general you know there
are people who are offended by people
who say black lives matter with people
who wear pins that say that but people
who don't believe my ground should be
dead right now there are people offended
by that they offended by the truth
they're out to protect their own white
supremacy beliefs and their privilege
those times people those are like bottom
right I don't pay them any attention so
yeah people are offended by things that
make them feel uncomfortable they're not
able or they're not ready yet to face
the realities of what black people
experience globally
of course when someone makes a bold
statement like hands up or black lives
matter
they're going to feel like all eyes
matter you know or my Brown desert he
should have been a criminal you
shouldn't get this and it shouldn't have
done that but we are know you feel
guilty
mmm I don't think I don't think races
are completely even thoughtful enough to
know what it even feel guilty about I
think that they I think they are very
committed to protecting what serves them
which is white supremacy and I think
guilt comes from self-reflection I think
it comes from a lot of times I feel you
have to think about your actions you
have to think about what you said in
order to elicit some feeling of guilt
how you respond to the guilt you know
that depends on each individual is to
even feel it I feel like you have to put
some thought into it white supremacist
races they do what they do and that is
to protect the system that protects them
it is to keep keep things in order the
way that it always has been I don't
think that guilt is even a an option
when it comes to white supremacist they
don't feel so what do you think will
happen when the film who streets screens
in throughout the entire state of
Missouri well I saw a preview on
Facebook and I score through the
comments I usually don't do that but I
did and it was a lot of people who
wanted to talk about how Mike Brown was
a criminal and that's why he was killed
and the black lives matter movement is
useless and we don't do anything when
black on black crime happens but we
protest police brutality the same things
that people always do
try to invalidate the movement and try
to invalidate why the uprising occurred
and why a brazen session occurring
nationwide still like it's going to be
the same thing it's going to be people
wanting to invalidate what is true with
their reasons for why black life should
be deemed just worthless you know I
expect that I expect a lot of pushback I
expect it'll be uncomfortable
I expect people to want to argue about
why the film is is a dishonest or why
you know there's this thing where people
now have created this narrative where
black lives matter automatically means
that you're anti police so that's going
to be another it's going to be a
conversation people are probably calling
an anti-police film but well I don't
want to give away too much about the
film but I think it's in the middle and
you're very powerful scene where you're
showing a woman a woman of color and
you're saying things to her and she
can't speak but her face shows that she
wants to say something and it's a really
powerful scene so I don't think it
totally paints it anti-law enforcement
but I have heard people ask why didn't
we get the police perspective the media
already does that so for someone even
accent they framed it like oh well this
seems like you're just trying to capture
the voices of the community and you
didn't even act the police how they so
we don't need to because every time you
turn on the television and the the the
narrative is set already they've already
told the police story they were afraid
they fear for their lives they who knows
you know but the narrative has already
been set by mass media what opportunity
to people ever have to tell their own
stories when that police officer that
black woman was on the brink of tears in
that film was a very powerful thing I
don't think it's speaks volumes
I don't think we need to hear what she
has to say to understand in that moment
she was probably torn between working
for a system that does not care about
her or her family or her black children
and facing a community who is finally
standing up to the system that she works
for declaring that they have the right
to live and that they matter and that
they're not backing down and that they
won't answer it and they want justice
and they want the whole system
dismantled because it's guilty you know
that she had to be torn in pieces but I
don't feel like I need to get to police
perspective in order in order to know
that like it's all over her face in that
particular scene yeah definitely a Nazi
I mean you do have like these I don't
know if they're city council meetings
but there's definitely you see the
stamps it's it I think that it's pretty
clear what a certain part of the
community feels and that's what's just
wondering who is the movie for if you
feel that maybe change is not possible
and maybe you're right some things are
so ingrained and certain people's mind
that it's not possible who is the movie
for the movie is for people who want to
know the truth about what happened in
Ferguson who wanted on the ground look
at what people who were involved in the
movement the movement works the
underground work that took place the
response of the police to protesters who
want to know how we were treated why we
rose up in the first place
that's what the movies for is for people
who aren't honest answers and honest
perspective about what actually happened
in Ferguson and even the movie it only
captures the perspective of four or five
people you know it's not everyone I mean
I'm pretty sure we could go on for hours
we can probably even create a series of
the experiences that people in st. Louis
faced during the Ferguson uprightness
there's hundreds of people who sit
there are hundreds of people who came
out of their house and we're fighting
for their lives but who straights Damon
and survived captured a number of people
to tell a greater story this is the
truth this is what happened you know in
a completely counters every single media
narrative that has ever come out of
Ferguson you had said or or I don't know
if it was just the film said that social
media was actually more accurate in
terms of depicting what was going on and
then a lot of the media had their own
bias can you talk about what that was
like being there especially during those
what was it like a hundred days yeah
when you fell or maybe he didn't but a
duty to put out things that maybe
contradicted what the big outlets were
showing
yes I all of the the events that I could
rely on like things that I knew they
were actually taking place I had to find
out from social media and i broadcast it
on social media there was one particular
time I will never forget we were out in
Ferguson when I pour milk on people who
had been tear yes there was like an
armored truck going up and down streets
and shooting out canisters that anyone
who who they saw on the streets there's
still people out there and happened
Anna's on their face now their hands are
up and these this armored trucks just
kept shooting canisters and like
watching people scattered like roaches
this is in a residential neighborhood so
this is a neighborhood where their
houses and side streets and children
live in these houses and they were going
up and down the street shooting tear gas
canisters down these streets these
streets are blocked off these cement
like wall beings where you couldn't
drive in and out they wanted to keep
people from protesting so they put those
up in the neighborhood so people can
even leave their homes so we went over
when I support milk on people who were
tear gassed because they couldn't see
they were like
gasping for air that night as we were
doing that a truck turned the corner an
armored truck and I can't remember if
they were shooting out tear gas or
rubber bullets I can't remember all I
know is that when we saw that it was
myself and maybe four or five others we
just took off running and I had to like
clear this fence because I just didn't
have time to open it it hit so we're
running super fast I cleared this fence
and we're in this backyard of who knows
I don't know whose home it was over like
face down in the grass in this backyard
while this armored truck drives down the
back street behind the house of the yard
we're landing and the police is on the
mic and the police it's a white guys
like get the home
leave the neighborhood you like
that and then the light shines on us and
then we hear more tear gas canisters and
then at some point we get up and we go
to the car and we're in the car I'm
scrolling through Twitter and Don Lemon
is on TV reporting that everything is
peaceful that night in Ferguson you know
that's why we have to tweet that's why
we have to put everything on social
media because while Don Lemon is down
the block
saying everything is peaceful tonight
because of the curfew because of Ron
Johnson things are nice tonight in
Ferguson
we're facedown in grass because the cops
are tear gassing people and we're trying
to pour milk on them so they can at
least either finish finish protesting
doing what they're doing or they can get
home so those are the kind of
contradictions that occur that occur
every single day lastly I know we have
to wrap up unfortunately but advice for
anyone whether it's a woman a mother who
wants to turn their life over but they
have no other choice that they can't
just lead a normal life like they had
May
before things have changed for them
whatever causes what's your advice to
them on day-to-day life dealing with
anxiety you gotta take care of yourself
this work is for the long haul you know
I don't think I know I'm not gonna see
freedom I don't know if my daughter's
going to see it but it's a lots of fight
you know we're in it for the long run if
you want to commit your life to doing
this type of work you've got to take
care of yourself you got to love on your
family you have to understand that
you're doing your part and that you
can't you can't do everything you can
you don't want to self-sacrifice for for
the sake of the movement you know
because you need to be here you know you
need to be present people are depending
on you and you have to prioritize and
you have to really think about what how
you want to be impactful to this words
how you want your commitment to black
and brown people to look and then you
you act but along the way you have to
have to take care of yourself daily
knowing when to step back knowing when
to step up knowing that you don't have
to take on everything I wish I would
have known that early on and I didn't I
had to learn that I was ten toes down
all the way in you know and it came with
sacrifice a huge sacrifice so I would
say there's plenty of work to do
plenty and it will be for a long time so
if you don't--if you gon get into it
just make sure that you take care of
yourself along the way yeah